-Now I thought I'd share
some of my favorite
worst-gift-ever stories
from you guys.
Here we go.
This first one's
from @iPopEditor.
He said, "One year,
I unwrapped..."
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Oh.
-Your gift was the truth.
-Yeah.
[ Light laughter ]
-This one's
from @GrizzBongoLady.
-Oh, yeah.
-She says,
"One year for Christmas..
[ Laughter ]
That's great.
-Yeah.
-That sounds like
something I would do.
That's fantastic.
-It's the lack of thought
that counts.
-This one is from @Kejade.
She says, "I gave my mom...
To the man I love. Ooh.
[ Laughter ]
[ Applause ]
-Mom.
-This one is
from @HeidiHoNayber.
Oh, Heidi --
-Hidey-ho, neighbor.
-Hidey-ho, yeah.
Hidey-ho, neighbor.
I got it.
She says, "In 1985...
[ Laughter ]
What?
-Ooh, what?
-You had to gag the bear?
-Ugh!
-Bingo Bear.
-Hidey-ho, neighbor.
-I never heard of Bingo Bear.
This one's from @darciecf.
She says, "One year
for Christmas...
They sent a photo.
Look at this thing.
Holy moley!
[ Laughter ]
That is weird.
-Wow.
-That is absolutely weird.
-It's like that's a gift
of nightmares.
-Oh, my God.
This one is
from @RebeccaAkbas.
She says, "My ex gave me..."
[ Laughter ]
Yeah, it's like, sweet, but --
[ Cheers and applause ]
Could've just dawn them
on a card or something.
I don't need those gloves.
This one's from @ashar0.
He says, "This year I opened..
[ Laughter ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
-At least it's not
a scratch n' sniff.
I mean, that's --
This is from @emmaviverios.
Viverios?
She says, "One year, my mom..."
[ Laughter ]
Aah!
[ Cheers and applause ]
All -- All the toys had no eyes.
This ones from @danaelecrae.
She says, "My coworker...
Look at the photo.
Hey, boy!
Hey, now.
-Hey, now.
Squirrels like buns.
This last one is
from Nestle Toll House.
-Oh, the cookie makers.
-They make the chocolate chips.
-Yeah.
-They sent one in,
and they said
the worst gift is...
There you go.
Not bad!
Not bad, Nestle!
I like that!
Toll House!
There you have it.
Those were our
"Tonight Show Hashtags."
To check out more of our
favorites, go to...